bonsoir à mais là ça marche pas parce
que à la base ils sont 2 1 2 3 bonsoir
mais du coup il voilà qu'il n'y a pas la
deuxième personne ne s'était pas mcfly
carlitos du coup ça c'est du grand crac
et c'est pas grave bonsoir et bonjour
parce qu'en plus ça marche pas du tout
on idée la vidéo elle sera 6h du matin
donc en fait pour qu'on dirait bonsoir
c'est pas faux bonjour et bienvenue pour
ce nouveau casse tête ça fait un peu le
télé achat des casse tête la semaine
dernière avec le hic on vous a fait un
petit cadenas pour libérer une pièce là
je reviens un peu aux fondamentaux du
début de l'été à savoir essayer d'ouvrir
une boîte si elle s'appelle la boîte
d'einstein autrement appelé en anglais
la spyder boxe s'il n'ya clairement rien
à voir je sais pas pourquoi en france il
le rappeler la boîte d'einstein
moi je trouvais ça sympa parce que
einstein est jamais loin dans mes vidéos
par contre la spyder boxe ça me
paraissait un peu probable puisque on à
l'araignée qui est ici la boîte c'est
toujours du matos artisanales comme
d'habitude et finement fait et on va
commencer par voir comme d'habitude sur
les boîtes
quels sont les éléments que je peux
bouger qu'est-ce qui est déplaçable ou
pas il faut quand même savoir que cette
petite boîte qui n'a l'air de rien et un
niveau de difficulté extrême
donc j'espère réussir à l'ouvrir en une
vidéo
alors la première étape c'est ça quand
il ya du métal il ya peut-être des
aimants
et si un aimant du coup il faut trouver
léman pour pouvoir enlever ça comme dans
la pointe de la boxe je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de la porte de la boxe je
vous la met juste au dessus de moi ici
aussi ça doit être ici l'air et on avait
avec philippe roesch enlevé comme ça des
tiges avec un aimant bon on va faire
face par phase ça me paraît mieux ça on
voit que c'est un bloc solidaire mais
quand même je me méfie de ce qu'ils ont
fait là les dessins avec avec la toile
d'araignée ça pourrait être aussi pour
déguiser ou pour cacher une partie
complètement amovible dans l'occurrence
pensais pas du tout c'est juste le bord
de cet élément là et ça ça m'a pas dit
un mot vide je la lève un petit peu
parce que j'aimerais pas en appuyant
bloqué quelque chose
ok donc là sur sa place gauche on a à
peu près les mêmes représentations ça ça
fait partie de cette planche ces points
là c'est le site celle là et c'est alors
ici on a un axe qui bouge et qui est
clairement levier d'ici je sais pas si
vous voyez bien ici que ça se lève
légèrement très légèrement quand
j'appuie juste là donc j'imagine qu'on a
le même chose de l'autre côté hockey
donc ça soit c'est un axe de levier soit
c'est au contraire quelque chose qui
bloque et qu'il faudrait essayer
d'enlever ce qui est possible je ne sais
pas en fait si ce qu'on voit là le noir
6 et solidaire de la gelée un petit peu
vite aujourd'hui sur les explications et
vous savez la première phase sur les
boîtes c'est comme dans les escales
games et de faire une phase
d'exploration de voir qu'est ce qui
bouge qu'est ce qui bouge pas quelles
sont les actions possibles qu'on a à
faire dessus et sachant que c'est une
difficulté extrême forcément je mets mes
filles à l'ewf cette boîte parce que
allah l'air de rien tu te dis pas
vraiment tu te dis pas en voyant ça ça
va être une difficulté extrême et la
difficulté je la voie directe avec le
fait que rien ne bouge
nulle part tiens j'ai vraiment juste
accès à la barre elle est entière allait
vraiment solidaire à la barre comme sac
qui traverse de part en part et qui est
clairement rattaché à ça et quand je dis
j'ai accès c'est arrivé elle touchée
avec la pulpe de mon doigt en poussant
bien fort l'autre chose que j'ai réussi
à faire donc là en appuyant ça fait rien
et si on appuie vraiment ici par contre
on voit que ça s'ouvre donc il faut que
j'arrive à comprendre qu'est ce qui
bloque le système pour peut-être partir
du blocage pour aller ensuite vers le
déblocage
là je suis pas juste comme dans rain man
je suis en train de voir comme avec le
cadenas qu'on a fait au tout début du
mois d'août le canal 64 qui était très
très dure voire s'il n'y a pas une bille
ou quelque chose qui bouge intérieur je
me dis en fait il n'a pas de mouvements
mécaniques en touchant peut-être qu'il
ya quelque chose sur une rotation
quelque chose comme ça à quiberon alors
ça c'est moi ta je me suis auto franck
c'est comme dans les vidéos de fantômes
en fête où il ya quelqu'un qui marche et
qui fait bouger quelque chose et puis
son quotidien est un fantôme
non c'est pas forcément ça retombe un
peu plus il empêche d'ouvrir
j'arrive pas à comprendre si ce qu'ils
empêchent c'est justement ce qui est ici
là de part en part du trou ou si c'est
plus par là devant ils pensaient que la
salle retiendrai
parce que dans ces cas là ce serait pas
du tout un levier si elle se trouve elle
de l est mais non je répondais le maire
veut n'importe quoi en fait là on voit
deux petits picots de bois qui rendent
directement en fait dans les trous donc
on voit en même temps qu'ils sont
solidaires on peut pas je pourrai pas
enlever le couvercle autrement qu en
ouvrant la boîte comme ça c'est à beaune
indices il en parle en inde isnard et
nice donne peut-être un indice en fait
sinon pourquoi faire une araignée et
faire toute une toile comme ça donc
l'araignée elle regarde dans cette
direction-là du mois j'ai l'impression
d'être la forme de ses pattes temps à me
faire penser qu'elle regarde précisément
ici juste là
ça donne envie d'appuyer quand même
allez fort fort jolie cette boîte mais
je sens qu'il va vite me rendre dernier
en plus c'est un truc qui m'énerve de
départ j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi il ya cette forme là ici
pourquoi ils n'ont pas coupé droit à
peut-être juste pour laisser une marge
de sécurité à la découpe pour ça ajoute
à ça me rend dingue
en fait les castes et qui a jamais rien
qui est fait au hasard tout un sens il
faut pas avoir du sens des fois partout
dans la résolution sa pelouse du sens
comme là je me dis sa dette par rapport
à la fabrication
peut-être c'est rien ça commence à
s'ouvrir à ça c'est hier à l'intérieur
ici donc direct puis exploiter ce volume
là en fait deux
[Musique]
bon il ya deux choses qui m'embête tout
ça fait un petit moment là quand même
que je suis dessus
en fait ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est de visualiser la boîte en 3d dans
ma tête comme on a déjà pu faire sur
deux casquettes celle je suis en mode
sérieux là je suis en mode vraiment
sympa mais pas ce que je veux j'arrive
rien à voir par l'extérieur donc il faut
comprendre comment marche l'intérieur il
ya deux trucs qui m'embête sur cette
botte il ya ça il ya aucune raison pour
qu'une partie métallique ici donc pour
moi mais talent égal et ment et il ya ce
petit truc noir et en fait de tout à
l'heure je me dis à quoi ça sert
si ce n'est pas pour retenir vers
l'avant je pense que c'est pas ici que
c'est bloqué que c'est ici que ça qu'on
n'arrive pas et du coup c'est quand même
beaucoup d'éléments qui se retrouverait
devant et je trouve que ma théorie elle
marche on a on a un bout de métal ici et
pour moi métal ces aimants et ça en fait
si on regarde partout à chaque fois
qu'on avait un truc noir sur cette boîte
un élément fossé c'est un élément d'une
autre planche donc ils ont été obligés
dévider pour mettre quelque chose ici en
supplément dans ma tête
j'imagine que ce petit bout de bois là
c'est un espèce de crochets comme ça
comme un 1/2 on va dire on a trois
quarts de un peu comme un hameçon et
qu'à l'intérieur y ait une tige qui
passe soit dans ce sens-là hameçons et
tiges soit au contraire c'est lui qui
fait la tige et il ya un endroit qui en
scène ça et qui fait que que au moment
de lever en fait on peut pas parce qu'il
ya quelque chose qui bloque
voyez un peu l'idée quoi donc j'ai une
idée pour le débloquer
mais si c'est ça si la réponse c'est ça
c'est bat à l'eau thermale il ya un truc
qu'on peut pas faire avec les
casse-têtes ses forces et je dis bien
dans normal parce que l'ade ya des
papiers où il ya juste marquer il suffit
d'appuyer et c'est là il n'y avait pas
d'indication du tout aucune 0 indication
donc soit ils en ont pas mises soit
c'est qu'on a le droit de faire à peu
près tout ce qu'on veut avec
je me dis c'est associer une action
mécanique comme ça
s'agit coup j'ai cru l'espace d'un
instant j ai cru si on attend on attend
le métal en plus au nord six là
j'entends clairement que c'est pas du
goût à la dent la route nice a fait
métalliques
vous entendez une petite un petit
arrière sont de métal auquel je me dis
si anxieux en insertion n'arrive pas à
débloquer un peu c'était ça c'était
tellement ça ah [ __ ] je ne te
comprendre excusez moi je viens de
craquer la boîte d'einstein
on doit ce check et du cou
[Musique]
une
ça c'est la preuve par einstein qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a fait un chèque à
quelqu'un aux points ok mortels mais
trop trop malin trop beaucoup trop malin
en fait comme boîte je les vis alors pas
complètement par hasard parce que j'ai
ce que ce que j'avais imaginé c'est
vraiment en grande partie ce cas dedans
mais je pense qu'il ya une petite part
de hasard après sur la fin alors ce que
je pensais être un bon c'est pas ici
c'est un gros bloc tout seul perforé
d'un trou par contre j'avais raison sur
le principe que c'est une pièce qui
était bien rajouter à ici d'où ce truc
noir le bout de métal qui me faisait
penser à un aimant c'est clairement pas
du tout un aimant à se mentir c'est pas
séparément et à et voilà il vient de se
remettre mais par contre il y avait bien
une tige qui passait dans ce trou pour
l'empêcher de s'en sortir
ce qui fait que la germinative et
al'inverse peut pas fermer parce que la
tige
elle bloque mais on n'entend pas ce que
j'entendais tout à l'heure le bruit de
métal et du coup pour enlever le métal
il doit être lui retenu par un aimant
alors c'est quand j'ai tapé dans l'autre
sens
ah c'est ça ok pour enlever le métal il
faut ça c'est vraiment celle de leur
part il faut donner un coup sec sur la
table ou dans la main aux gens c'est
rien pour libérer la tige que vous voyez
ici et qui elle je pense au bout de ce
côté là est retenue par les mangez pas
un bout de métal moins forte fait
d'accord je cherchais je cherchais un
petit bout de métal de l'appoint de
rabat
[Musique]
je vais prendre le dément de la pandera
bruxe pour aller voir s'il ya bien un
aimant ici ça c'est bien tiges
métalliques ad'ailleurs du coup la
direction veut ça c'est peut-être dans
ma tête mais je me dis que la direction
de l'araignée elle va bien dans le sens
où il faut taper et oui voilà le refaire
on vous puissiez bien le voir là en fait
avec les mange saisie par l'intérieur la
petite tige métallique
je la ramène ici et donc il ya bien un
aimant au bout qui la retient mais qui
épargne montré puissant ce que je peux
même faire les allers-retours ce qui
explique pourquoi en donnant un petit
coup après ça repart ah oui là on sent
bien les moins c'est très malin c'est
très ingénieux mais c'est doublement
ingénieux de leurs phares dans le sens
où les habitués des casse têtes en fait
nous on sait qu'il faut pas qu'il faut
pas taper extrêmement hâte c'est
astucieux et ainsi si vous aussi vous
mettez ça dans les mains à quelqu'un
capable car l'habitude de faire des
cartes des casse tête je pense que
jamais il osera taper fait j'ai osé
parce qu'à un moment donné il fallait
bien il fallait bien aller sur une piste
mais en temps normal on ne violente pas
les casse-têtes ce n'est pas la méthode
de résolution
tu fais que pour le refermer il suffit
de faire ça et ça j'ai kiffé cette boîte
l' einstein box où la spyder boys ou la
met en lien dans la description pour
ceux que ça intéresse allez bah du coup
c'est une boîte avec une seule action de
pour pour la résoudre
et vous savez souvent les casse tête qui
ont une marge de manoeuvre
vous n'avez parlé dans une dernière
vidéo ce sont les casse têtes les plus
compliqués à résoudre parce que ben on
peut pas faire un step by step en fait
il faut tout de suite trouvé la bonne
idée de résolution j'aime bien elle part
dans mes boîtes préféré avec la pandora
box du coup je les range et ensemble
beaucoup trop cool
j'aime bien les boîtes les bottes ça
fait partie en fait de mes cassettes et
de préférer au final mais après 6 passes
les toujours les plus longs à résoudre
ou en tout cas les plus saisissants a
parlé step by step mais ça c'est très
très cool merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo pensez à lalique et quand même
si elle vous a plus assez cool vous
abonner à la chaîne s'est pas encore
fait je vous mets autour de moi quelques
anciens casse tête le prochain sera
mercredi prochain à 6 heures et on sera
deux ici on fera deux casse-tête mais
oublie ses farouches qu'on en profite et
en parlant de profiter cette transition
est incroyable n'oubliez pas qu'il ya
des spectacles à l'olympia le 22
septembre reste plus beaucoup de places
il est temps de réserver vous allez le
lien dans la discrétion et sa part
ensuite ce spectacle-là en tournée dans
plus de 40 villes c'est aller les dettes
sur mon site fabien olicard point fr un
très bientôt ciao